I'm in the Arctic Circle and the
big question for me is, "Why?"
The great outdoors
means different things
to different people.
I'm more the great indoors
type of guy.
But I've agreed to explore what
lies outside my comfort zone.
A world I've spent
my whole life avoiding.
Woah, woah, woah.
- Beautiful mountain.
- That's a volcano.
That's a volcano?
I think I'm feeling a
heart attack coming on.
I'm not entirely sure what
I signed up for.
But what's the worst
that can happen?
Oh, my god.
First time I've had my
hand up an elephant's...
[elephant trumpets]
I like to avoid violence at all cost.
How you doing over there?
Not bad, I'll be opening
my eyes momentarily.
Just surviving...
would be great.
- You need some help?
- No, I got it.
There is a world outside the resort.
We always try to find the positive way.
- Pura vida!
Woah!
It's about what's really important:
nature,
family,
the friends that I met.
I'm going for it.
Let the screaming begin.
Oh, my god.
This is the last time I have
five vodkas with a Finn.